je voulais crier encore au secours mais
il m'a mis le point dans la bouche
et puis maintenu son oreiller pour que
les moyens de le manteau ne pas crier
dans les années 70 des femmes osez enfin
briser le tabou des violences conjugales
à la télévision des témoignages
audacieux à une époque où frapper sa
femme étaient pour certains un acte
banal et parfois même revendiquer un
coup malheureux
moi aussi je veux tapé ma femme mes
chèques la famille l'amour à certaines
familles lors faut faut leur faire
rentrer à coups de poing en avril 1979
les femmes battues témoignait aussi sur
les plateaux tv l'émission les dossiers
de l'écran leur consacrait une édition
spéciale j'avais honte de dire aux
voisins que mon mari m'avait tapé quand
j'avais un bleu sur la figure je ne
sortais pas de chez moi ça m'est arrivé
une fois pendant trois mois j'ai pas mis
les pieds dehors cette autre femme aux
mêmes affiches et les marques de la
violence qu'elle subissait je crois
qu'il faut que les femmes qui sont
battus n'ai pas honte comme le plus
souvent elles ont honte c'est moi c'est
ce matin que j'ai réfléchi à la la
nécessité impérieuse pour moi de
m'exprimer parce que j'en avais le
chouette des récits poignants encourager
à l'époque par l'association sos femmes
battues via sa permanence téléphonique
d'urgence d'abord mais aussi au travers
des médias pour sensibiliser l'opinion
publique à ce fléau social certains
entretiens entre les victimes et les
membres de l'association sont parfois
filmées entre il faut que vous m'aidiez
je peux plus rester si je voudrais un
autre attente le pays vivre avec mes
enfants pour punir ap le repos
finalement aucune possibilité
d'hébergement accueillent pour faire
évoluer les mentalités des actions de
sensibilisation aux violences conjugales
se multipliaient aussi en france
sensibiliser l'opinion publique gens
prennent conscience enfin qu'il ya des
femmes battues des femmes qui ont été
battus pendant qu'il reprend des années
pendant dans leurs propres foyers et que
maintenant enfin à the prendre la parole
justement alors qu'avant elle se taisait
vous avez honte c'étaient les victimes
qui avaient honte
depuis 1994 les violences conjugales
sont officiellement reconnus comme un
délit en france mais le fléau reste
difficile à éradiquer
selon les derniers chiffres officiels en
2018 sans vingt-et-une famourette encore
sous les coups de leur conjoint ou ex
conjoint
[Musique]